[Music]
foreign
what do you think like worked in that
show and what do you think didn't work
in that show
so I think one it was it was a sensitive
it still is a sensitive thing for
Baltimore because I ran into that task
force actually did you uh like d did all
of us
yeah yeah and they just um I was gonna
bite my balls
but um you know where the drugs at where
the money like you know what you got or
whatever and they didn't get all of them
right so it's like they still exist and
so even when the officer got killed
people were like some police officers
that I'm friends with message me is like
don't don't uh post anything or whatever
they took uh you know all the the video
footage from the neighborhoods they had
like a certain neighborhood on lockdown
and like kept everybody quiet so I was
like I ain't messing with that yeah
because like they come get you it's too
serious yeah it was
it was raw man I mean I mean if you
think about that was 2018 and like it
was funny because the first time I don't
know if it's funny but the first time
you know I was a huge fan of DS yeah
because I read uh his our most hated cop
in Baltimore oh yeah Universal yeah
right I read that like a year before and
I reached out to him and I was like and
it wasn't only just that that story was
so amazing right but I was just so taken
with the fact that like he went about
that story with such empathy he would it
wasn't just like this is the bad guy I'm
the good guy it was he just got the new
one yeah I mean as you know it's so much
more complicated than that and we are so
much more alike than we are different
and that dude over there that you want
to judge that could be you and it yeah
circumstances and I just I was just so
taken with the piece and so taken that
he wanted to dive into that character
yeah so I reached out to him like a
[__] fan girl dude I was just like
yeah because then I love him yeah the
cook up that I read these and I was just
like dude you that you are just it and
um yeah you know I have this project
I've been working on about uh Shreveport
Louisiana been working on for 10 years
we're doing it uh um now
um with the Saint George belcanos and
Ray green who directed it
um but but I was like D I just want to
be in your life like what's up and then
like a year later you know I found
myself when we owned the city with you
like yeah with Wayne Jenkins but we
would we would go and we would sit and
we would talk to people in Baltimore
yeah and I just a random person would go
and buy be like hey man have you ever
heard of Wayne Jenkins and everybody
yeah everybody knows what that is
everybody knows yeah it was Dee's
birthday
um a few three days ago so I was just
sending a message but I talked to him
all the time he helped me uh with my
book and I brought you a copy too yeah
thank you I really appreciate that but
uh this is dope and what do you think
like I mean I think with those
interestingly like you know you know
once the show gets out there since I'm
like yeah you know public about it and
it's my face out there a lot of people
talk to me about it but when you you
know those plain clothes units I mean if
you think about like what just went down
in Memphis Yeah Yeah it's like now those
guys weren't playing clothes like a lot
of the plain clothes units got missed
yeah you know because when you think
about like policing that way like trying
to put numbers on the board just trying
to make as many stops as you can for
whatever reason it's like you know the
more stops you have the Yeah the more
potential for for it to go the O'Malley
era when he was when he was mad well
they don't like it I mean I'm friends I
know everyone like in the city and most
of them don't like it but they don't
disagree they don't think it was like
inaccurate right so it's like
for us it's like all right we got the
wire which is like
uh one of the greatest shows ever we
think and but it does paint the city in
a certain kind of Light which we're like
what do you mean by that so so when
people people when they say oh yeah
you're from Baltimore and they say yeah
the wire or whatever and like we're
bigger than just the wire like it's we
got all kinds of talent some of the best
best artists in the world from there all
the stuff but it's like that's the first
thing they think of and so we're
sensitive to that so it's that City it's
weird because growing up myself as a DC
cat as well it's so crazy because I grew
up so I grew up in Cabin John and then I
went to school Northwest oh nice uh I
was being gone uh and uh spin gone and
then uh Chamberlain and uh Chamberlain's
in southeast but yeah I grew up with no
Feast did you
do any uh did you play sports as a kid
or I ran a trap you ready track okay
that's what's right yeah yeah and I was
on the chess team I played I played
chess competitively do you still play I
don't play anymore okay but I'm thinking
about jumping back in the game that's
what's up that's what's up but I think
like for me like DC versus Baltimore and
how for me growing up even playing
sports like boxing throughout the week
yeah I had nothing really to do with it
then when I made that show and I lived
there you know even though my family
still lives in DC I was in Baltimore the
whole time and I fell in love with the
city and and it is there's uh this it's
a brutal
yeah very Soulful City and I love the
people there yeah
it is very dangerous though yeah yeah I
mean it's yeah it's in your face yeah
and like when we there like I think
about it because I live in Baltimore the
house in Bolton Hill uh and I just
bought a vacation house in Miami and
then I have a apartment in New York and
when I'm in Baltimore and I know
everyone there but I'm still on the
swivel I'm looking for the police that's
right we don't go to the gas stations at
night yeah I'm guessing the stick up
boys like I'm like you know women like
yeah meet me here in the state well I
can't meet you there or just you know I
can't wait a Rollie certain neighbors
everything the whole thing even when I'm
out with dude we just we look around
like yeah yeah we talking we having a
good time but we like watching the door
we watch it all that yeah it's really
real man and you know I I did so much of
my time there was like three months
going on ride along and the cops are
like that like with the cops the cops
like don't stop at this like yeah just
keep going right yeah and they're like
yeah this street it doesn't it like
there were dudes who like told us you
know we'd be in a in a police car and
[__] would be like tapping on
the hood and being like y'all yeah yeah
yeah the same for you right here you
know and and uh yeah man but but but yes
there's so much uh Beauty there in the
soul there it's it's it's it's uh
palpable and it's alive I'm excited I
saw my homie uh Wes Moore yeah yeah so
he he wrote the intro to my book I saw
it and um
I I am I know the mayor uh but I'm more
I'm super excited that Wes is in Charles
has been a friend with him a long time
we've been through all kinds of stuff
together
uh but I think there's there's real hope
for uh City but also for for the state
agreed yeah so I'm excited about that he
has the ability to attract Talent he's
smart he's strategic yeah he's been
through it yeah he's been through it
he's been through all elements and like
yeah I don't know man I'm um you know
politicians scare the [__] out of me yes
like I'm kind of just like I like I just
kind of tapped out of that but when I
met him
um you know my best friend growing up uh
works with him okay and uh kid I play
football with you know Wes came from
playing football as well and
um and then that book is just like again
I think it's it's it's similar to to D
it's just the book was written with such
with such empathy and such like I mean
that's kind of like the whole root of
everything Wes was doing yeah we're
there for the grace of God go I you know
and and
um I I I thought that was beautiful but
but but do you I mean I'm just wondering
for me this ain't even about the show
yeah but like do you identify as a DC
cat or a Baltimore cat it's a good
question uh and I'm gonna tell the truth
and then we get in trouble for it
Baltimore really yeah and my family like
so my family I grew I was born and
raised in Washington DC they did my
cousin just called me yesterday said I
don't know why you rap in Baltimore why
you moved there you born here you from
here yeah and that's like but I like I
haven't been there like in a while and
there's no love for me and I said the
city's been gentrified and it has been
and they pushed everyone out and then
you know like you know it's just it's
just not the same what what neighborhood
did you grow up in I grew up in
Northeast like Lincoln Heights area like
a division at Division Avenue
um East Capitol Street like in that area
like back in the old DC so what uh like
90s yeah 80s
roughly around the same age yeah how
would you explain when when you say the
real DC because like you're right man it
is for me now going back even when I
went back together we own the city I was
like who like I want to tell people to
run for their lives like y'all can't be
here you know what I mean like I think
it's like no we got a yoga mat stay
walking their dogs and people like what
do you do why should I be talking to you
that's just some old people [__] anyways
because you remember when you were a kid
you know back in the day right I'm
wondering whether that's just because
we're old but like I am literally I know
there's gentrification everywhere yeah
but I feel like DC has like literally
just sort of like been lifted up and
then replaced with something else I
agree and and my family my family that
are still there and you know kudos to
them that they've moved up to the upper
the the black upper middle class so like
they every time I go and hang out with
them now like that's just like yeah like
Northwest and like on the water and
Southwest and got like nice places and
everything is is just is done over nice
but they sometimes say to me why are you
doing this work why did you move to
Baltimore why are you like why are you
going into prisons why are you doing
gang mediation why are you like in in
South Side Chicago
like [__] them like we made it look at
this and I said well what about all the
people that got pushed out that's right
like for in like the Anacostia is
probably like next like they're working
on them by like thousands of thousands
of people have been pushed to PG County
um Charles County uh maybe not
Montgomery County but maybe some but
that's like and then this and then it's
over it's Checkmate and now most people
can't afford like the people that we
grew up with they can't afford to live
in that's right they changed the names
of our neighborhoods y'all okay with
that that's crazy and they just like
but we made it yeah and it's like I'm
just not comfortable that doesn't sit
well with you yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]